would you advise guys before they were
to get married to spend
three hours in a family courtroom and to
spend at least an hour
on a lawyer's time to find out exactly
what he's walking into
which i could not agree more i think the
problem with a lot of guys is that
they're cheap
and men are you know thrifty we're cheap
we're the
you know more efficient sex but you know
i think
what happens is that you don't spend the
the ounce of prevention and then you've
got to spend like the
20 tons of cure you know it's it's
it's so great to have that advice up
front
to know what you're getting into not
just forget a prenup even if you're
not going to do a prenup so you should
still go in and
talk to a lawyer about it and also like
you said see the court system
look up what's going to happen just you
know do a little bit of research like
basic research
on the consequences or your state laws a
lot of them are written easily
so you can actually understand them and
even a lot of firms have explanations on
the firm website that give you basic
information about the law in your state
so
absolutely worth it absolutely all right
go ahead
yeah so i mean um you know talking about
why people get
married i've always read one um economic
theory of marriage which i thought was
interesting
which is people get married when times
are good and they get divorced when
times are bad
which i think is kind of what we're
seeing here so you know if you look at
what's to come
i imagine there's going to be a lot more
um you know divorce
doors ahead because obviously we're in
for economic tough times with the
continuing lockdowns the businesses
being shut down
that doesn't spell well for a lot of
small businesses and a lot of guys that
are related to those industries
and you know you're seeing uh an
increasing number
of um you know women once they get
divorced competing for a smaller and
smaller percentage of what they
find as uh economically economically
viable individuals
but if you are in that in that category
you definitely need to
spend the money in time because you've
spent so much money and time
on collecting those resources and then
you're just not going to protect them
it's like buying a lambo and not taking
on insurance why would you do that
so you know especially if you got a
business too you know
a lot of people don't realize that you
know you're if she can come off as
contributing to that business or leading
to a business success
that can a lot of states and
jurisdictions be factored in
so you know
you